let me ask a
very important fundamental question
about martial arts we're both wearing
a suit and tie uh joe rogan thinks that
wearing a tie is a huge disadvantage
is it a clip on or is it an actual tie
are you controlled by another one
so do you agree or disagree with joe
rogan that wearing a tie
is a is a martial arts
significant disadvantage in terms of
combat in a combat scenario
in a fight i think it would be a distant
disadvantage
yes okay but i i work as a as a security
bouncer
in nightclubs and event when i was 18
years old
yes and
[Music]
sometimes i had to work in a certain
event that i was in suit and tie
i never had to use
my force to take someone out when i
wasn't supentai
but if i would have had to before going
to the table to
physically take the guy out i would have
removed my tie
and i would have removed my vest for
sure and i would have called back
up for sure and i would have probably
used the element of surprise to
be first on that guy yes uh
when you're in a bar same thing you call
back up first
and and and you make sure you ask the
way the waitress before to clean the
table
before you go yeah and when you go
you have to use the element of surprise
yeah because fighting
fighting that makes martial and fighting
in the street it's two different things
and yes i'm a mix i'm a mixed martial
art competitor that's what i've done all
my life but i had a lot of street fight
in my life
a lot when i was in what's the
difference what's like the oh my god
it's
a huge difference there is guys that
if i would have a choice you know to
fight
like for example certain guys and you
have seen a street fight and fight
like other guys that are not in ufc i
would maybe sometimes
pick guys that are not in ufc not
necessarily because in
in in a street fight there's no referee
that says go
it's the element of surprise and when
you're a nice guy you're not the
aggressor
you always have the element of surprise
that's what it taught me oh interesting
yes because if aggression in your second
person will not come punch you without
warning
it needs to it needs to trigger some
it's something need to be triggered
before so if someone comes because he's
looking for trouble
there's a sign that is looking for
trouble so i was
just talking with fast food on this
weekend about it and i saw that
every every martial art yeah comes from
like some martial arts are from
exclusive week for competition
yes like sport karate uh like certain
martial art but traditional martial
martial art
are for the street or for self defense
and i start my background in kyokushin
karate so it's for and i did japanese
jujitsu so
my background before i even start
training for mixed martial art my
background is in self-defense
and it's very important to understand
that in a street fight
the element of surprise is everything
and there are no rules
you can go for the eyes the necks
it surprises everything total ball game
you know what i mean you have the
the chair the beard there's so much more
thing going on
so the idea of because you are a ufc
fighter you think you're invincible this
is
bs anybody can come like if a big guy
who punched very hard
most people don't know how to punch by
the way they don't know how to make a
fist and throw it in a forward direction
but if
someone knows how to do it i don't care
who you are if you could be
francis and genu someone come behind
your head and
hang or let's say there's an argument
and you get surprised by a punch
you can beat you up and lose a fight
that doesn't matter
the element of surprise is everything so
you were saying remove all the sources
of the elements to surprise all the
clear the bar
remove the tie i still disagree with you
about the tablet
but just for your information if someone
comes
looking for trouble and you see me do
this
and and going sideways yeah that's my
position that i'm i'm
thinking there you go maybe something
will happen and i'm about that's a good
i'm about
thinking about doing the element i'm
about to punch you or
to do to do something to to to take care
of this see to flip the table on you
then
wearing a tie is communicating the nice
guy
image so it actually gives you the
freedom for more elements of surprise
by wearing the tie if you take it off
that's more
you're limiting your options because
nobody's going to expect the guy in the
tie to do anything
i'm a big believer that sometimes it's
not only
materialism it's what you project
that's true like i had troubles in a bar
and i was able to deflect
the guy was looking for trouble talking
to me and i was able to deflect his own
aggressivity by saying like
hey man that's a nice shirt where did
you get it like saying like something
was
stupid like this then it it kind of
break
break the momentum and he you know but
the guy was looking for trouble
i don't want to fight you i don't want
to fight you but i'm not going to
wait until you pull you
you make the first move because the
first the minute you you touch me you
push me or you you touch me you declare
war and
the war is unleashed my friend and i'm
i'm taking you out of order
with the necessary force of course you
know i mean that's
the thing with martial art if you use
the necessary force to take out a
problem
it's okay but if you you know you you
take advantage of it that's when it's
not all right because it's a weapon
so if someone comes up to me that's my
position and
now i'm i'm assessing this situation you
know
that's that's how they teach in self
defense here never put your hands down
i wasn't there because i'm down or boom
like like
what this is this is very important and
you never
you always your center line on the side
ah yeah like this
if someone knows martial art he will
recognize that pattern
but if you go like if someone talk to
you and you go like this
that's mean you're telling the guy that
you want to fight you don't want to do
that you don't want to oh yeah
um that's that's interesting you know
that's
that's the position because your hand
are here you know whatever you can do
you're here
well also your ear tells the story
it's not everybody that knows that
however it some people might might think
that it's my mom grabbed me by the air
and pulled me because i didn't listen to
her you know
you